inside the walls of El Djem hoary
hospital and Aden patients are dying of
a mysterious respiratory illness the UN
says it's likely corona virus is
spreading undetected in Yemen doctors
are on alert yet the patients results
are negative the situation is very
tragic
during the last two days we've had two
deaths and then three deaths as the
result of infections in the respiratory
tract the strange thing is that the
corona virus tests are negative but the
symptoms of the cases suggest is a
similar disease or the corona virus is
present that was not diagnosed correctly
Yemen recorded its first case of corona
virus on April 10 there were no further
cases reported until Wednesday nearly
three weeks later here at Aden German
international hospital with five cases
were confirmed humans Health Minister
said two of those people died Yemen and
its health system have been ravaged by
five years of civil war the UN has
warned if coronavirus catches hold it
will be catastrophic only half of
Yemen's medical facilities are
functional the population is acutely
malnourished there is a cholera epidemic
and more than 24 million people need aid
to survive we expect the spread of more
cases but we can mitigate the spread if
people follow instructions with
protective measures like wearing face
masks social distancing staying at home
and washing their hands regularly
after the new cases were revealed a
brief curfew was enacted in Aden the
city closed its mosques in malls and
extended a shutdown of restaurants and
markets a number of private hospitals in
Aden stopped receiving patients in the
capital sana health workers have been
disinfecting and fumigating the streets
for more than a month this week they
moved in to disinfect shops in the busy
Bab al-salam marketplace after the
suspected cases were discovered we hope
that sterilization measures are
intensified and people adhere to wearing
masks and taking preventive measures
Yemen already the world's largest
humanitarian crisis trying to keep out a
pandemic that may already be in their
midst
Charlotte Bellis al Jazeera